I learned from it I went on to work on
TV again for a little bit to get my [ __ ]
together
and you couldn't have brought that same
experience the Davis cell comedy well I
had to go back into I hadn't done TV and
like [ __ ] like that in so long that's
why you were on my film set and you were
perfectly fine that oh and you had a
babysit me he I lived in this room
because he never could be on time
and it's to ensure that he would be on
set on time and I also paid her so damn
[ __ ] straight you did it was great
because the film didn't [ __ ] pay you
know yeah good times though I mean you
punched a wall oh okay let's give up
let's give a little context here so
number one you know I make a lot of
jokes like number one like I'm a [ __ ]
which I am I'm a huge [ __ ] however when
I was younger I used to have a very bad
temper not so much anymore not as bad as
it used to be
unless triggered to the point where like
it's like you really have to you really
have to treat me like [ __ ] to get me mad
like most of the time I say 99% of the
time I can joke about something laugh
about it turn it into a funny story rant
about it later and I'm pretty damn good
but we won't name the person who pissed
me off on set but somebody pissed me off
on set really really [ __ ] bad and
mind you it was to a point of it was a
level of disrespect that I don't think
anybody should be spoken to that way it
was a waste of your time it was a waste
of my time it was a buildup of like not
considering your time not considering my
time and you know partially cuz my film
too so it didn't really make sense and
you know because I'm I'm not passive but
I tried to be understanding about other
people's situation but it got to a point
where you know I'm looking over at the
schedule or I'm like no this is actually
done really poorly and so mind you I'm
doing my channel I'm doing a whole I
started up a couple of businesses at
that point and I'm doing the film at the
same time and so literally the amount of
time that I was sleeping was very very
[ __ ] minimal and the majority of the
sleep that I got was actually on set
when I was taking naps so it got to a
point where I was showing up on set like
five to six times and I just wasn't
doing anything and during that time I
could be
working on my other businesses and they
didn't need me on cent and they knew it
but they just never would never tell me
well just just in case they're like well
something switches up the thing is we
were getting so ahead of schedule they
started adding things and it made my job
difficult as well because it wasn't just
you we had so many other elements of the
film that I would have to call them ask
me hey can you actually come in today
yeah that's a little not how it runs
normally and so that's kind of it's the
whole situation was not it was not it
was just very stressful you know it was
a super low budget film and once again
I'm not talking about these gripes as if
you know somebody should feel sorry for
us we knew what we were in for but there
were definitely certain things that just
wasn't being considered just because
there's a lot of situation then
basically somebody says something mian
said that really just just got me to a
point where number one I don't like
being like that I don't like getting
angry like for real for real and so I
got [ __ ] mad and I literally just saw
red I grabbed his [ __ ] chair and I
was I was thinking about grabbing this
chair and [ __ ] smashing it over this
fools head but instead you punched the
chair first yeah but but nobody has seen
you that angry but me and so I just sat
there everyone was freaked out that you
need to let him let it out if somebody's
gonna get punched they just gotta let me
get angry so I literally just broke this
[ __ ] chair smash this table walked
over to a [ __ ] wall and then I just
started pounding my fist into it until I
couldn't feel my fist but you also you
were about to punch that fence but then
I saw you register it wasn't ours so
then you were like I'm gonna punch a
brick wall I'll consider I had even when
I'm angry there was like a loose tooth
fence at his house and I found the punch
it but I'm like this is not my house so
I hit the wall instead I saw the thought
process happen as well and then at we
had someone tried to go up to her and I
literally stopped him I said you need to
stay away from him or he will kill you
like just let him express everything and
then he'll sit down and be calm yeah so
essentially what happened was at that
point like the person that made me upset
was like the reason why it kind of
tipped me over was because that person
would be very disrespectful towards me
and he just goes - well that's [ __ ]
show business and then I was I didn't
what'd you just say to me bro you know
and it just it was it was I don't like
being demeaned you know like it just it
didn't it did not it was the last thing
I [ __ ] needed especially on my own
set it was also your one day off like we
got six days a week we only had one day
off technically and that was like one of
your only days off for me to sleep just
sleep mind you I mean every part of the
film yeah and then so like when they
were like oh can you call and I had
already been on set and it was a
last-minute thing
and they're like can you call David and
tell them to be on set and I remember
saying are you guys sure you're gonna
use him this is not okay you've already
called him like four different times the
other day like last week like he's gonna
be pissed and they're like no we're
gonna use him blah blah blah and then
the timing he just ended up sitting
there for like seven hours doing
absolutely [ __ ] nothing
and you know for most sets to like honor
that'll happen but you're getting paid
for it you know and I know this is my
film and stuff but at the same time it
was big damn well knew they didn't need
me know it was also at a point where we
were exhausted
it was a lot happening and no sleeping
for a [ __ ] month it's kind of tiring
you know I've had it just it just got
really bad and you know like I don't
think I handled the situation maybe as
well as I would if I was well rested but
I basically took the dude aside and I
said you know you need to apologize and
if you ever talk to me like that again
I'm just gonna [ __ ] you up or we could
just handle it you know and like who
does that sound like a David Stoll thing
like I would never say that to somebody
you know so it was just like it was just
like this very weird situation I don't
really like it but it is what it is
David so is a nice guy tell you piss him
off which is very hard to do it's very
very hard to do and I'm not saying that
I like when this happens I'm like i'ma
beat everybody up there's like a 80%
chance I'm gonna get my ass kicked
however I'm willing to take that [ __ ]
risk yeah yeah I mean that one was a it
was I was laughing that whole thing
happened because like these guys didn't
understand I gonna piss him off well
they just kept poking me you know and
it's like this is not and then when it
finally happened everyone was so scared
I was laughing cuz I'm like he's about
to swell up and he's gonna [ __ ] be so
sorry he just like everybody was nice so
nice after they were a fear deal no and
they were and they were better at
scheduling everybody else's [ __ ] too cuz
you know I had a conversation you
weren't you weren't the only person that
complained about it yeah so but it
shouldn't have gone to the point where I
flip out and tell people like you'll
[ __ ] do this [ __ ] right
and then now people are there scheduling
it better it's like you go come on yeah
but you know you live and you learn
yes is what it is well what did you
learn today I learned that I make bad
choices and I need to reevaluate how I
go about it good would you learn today I
learned that you're still stupid Here I
am piece of [ __ ]
no anyways guys